today we are checking out the brand new
Asus Rog Ally which is a handheld gaming
PC that you can take anywhere I cannot
wait to check this out I have already
seen a bunch of people posting their
unboxings and reviews and now we have
one here in the studio so let's open it
up
look at this oh man it looks so good
like I love the white I love the design
the buttons everything I love the RGB
lights and the joysticks ah okay let's
get it out of here
it looks so great oh my goodness it
feels good in the hands it's nice it's
light too which is actually surprising
because in a lot of the photos and
videos it looks like it would be very
heavy let's see what else we have in the
Box
we've got a 65 watt charger USBC and
some paperwork you know I'll file this
away in here just in case I ever want to
do some light reading
nice long cable because probably gonna
keep this plugged in a lot because the
battery life I mean considering what we
have here I don't think the battery life
is going to be that incredible that I'm
going to be able to just game for 10
hours straight without being plugged in
[Music]
it's powered by an AMD ryzen Z1 extreme
processor with AMD Radeon graphics this
should give you enough performance to
run most newer games at higher settings
with smooth frame rates it has a 7 inch
1080p display that supports variable
refresh rate and it has low frame rate
compensation for tear free and
stutter-free gaming even at lower frame
rates it has a built-in 8 000 milliamp
hour battery which most reviewers say
they've gotten around one to two hours
of gaming time depending on frame rate
and various settings depending upon how
quickly you want to rip through your
battery life this will support up to 120
hertz refresh rate it will go up to 500
nits of brightness and it also has a
Corning Gorilla glass dxc coating that
allows for fewer Reflections I love the
design and the look of this it has an
asymmetrical stick layout it has these
flat faced buttons and two paddles on
the back it has 512 gigs of storage and
it's also expandable with a Micro SD
card this runs on Windows 11 which means
you can access all of your favorite
games from Steam epic Xbox game pass and
more Armory crate shows you all of the
games that you have installed across all
platforms this makes launching and
finding what you want to play so much
easier than having to open all of the
separate launchers individually the
command center lets you control your
in-game experience with real-time data
monitoring enabling an FPS limiter and
more you can also customize your
controller to your liking with various
key mapping options there are also some
really great accessories like this this
is the Rog gaming charger dock so this
will let you connect this to a TV so you
can play multiplayer games and there's
even a pro setup that you can connect in
XG mobile external GPU monitor mouse and
a keyboard they also just released this
awesome controller called the recuri pro
it has this built-in tiny little OLED
display it's also got dedicated buttons
for switching between controller
profiles and try mode connectivity which
means you can connect over USB 2.4
gigahertz RF or Bluetooth it's designed
to work with PC and Xbox platforms and
since the Rog Ally is basically a little
PC these two are a perfect match this
thing is so cool and it has me hyped for
traveling back and forth between my
place and my parents house when I go to
visit them this is basically like a tiny
Windows machine so you have your Windows
login you've got like the windows
taskbar like it really is just a small
little PC this is where it brings in
your game Library so this just quickly
gives you access to all of your games
you'll see on Steam I have a Call of
Duty being downloaded right now wait is
it already downloaded can I play Call of
Duty right now
no not yet okay wait yes oh it's
happening okay now it's still
downloading I just got so excited there
were so many emotions right there oh my
gosh yeah that's what we have happening
right now we've got Diablo in Call of
Duty both being downloaded and it's
great because this really does feel just
like it's like a big
it's like a big phone
but a small PC if that makes any sense
so on the top here we've got some fans
which are currently blowing out some
warm air but it's not that loud now this
does have the back paddle buttons which
when I'm playing Call of Duty I've been
so used to having these back paddle
buttons to crouch and jump so I'm
definitely hyped that this is an option
here it feels pretty good in my hands
like everything
okay well I'm I'm now controlling a
YouTube video which is not what I should
be doing but none of my games have
downloaded yet so as soon as those get
downloaded I'll be able to actually play
so I have Ally connected to my 80 inch
tv and I'm going to be using the Asus
Rog recuri Pro Controller and if you do
get this definitely plug it into the
Ally with the USB cable and do an
updates also a note that if you do get
the Ally there is this little cardboard
stand that is easily mistaken for trash
it is not in fact trash it is a little
stand so we've got Forza Horizon 5
loaded up and we're gonna select our car
I think I'm gonna go I'm gonna come with
the Bronco no I'm gonna go with the
Corvette just a reminder this entire
gameplay is being run off of the Asus
Ally like this is pretty incredible
oh
[Applause]
get out of my way Pig
get out of my way
shoot okay I'll back up
[Music]
so far everything is running really
smoothly and the thing that I also like
about this controller is you can
actually adjust how the tension is on
the triggers with these little buttons
in the back so I'm going to relax them a
little because in this particular game
you kind of want to have more trigger
control let's do it we're gonna we're
gonna erase let's freaking do it
oh oh no oh no we're we're going off the
track oh gosh I'm out of I'm I'm
actually out of control right now I'm
not trying to drift I'm just trying to
drive like they gave me points so I'll
take it I miss my checkpoint
[Music]
oh no let's go let's go you're almost
there
these tight turns through this city are
not my friend
and there we are at the Finish Line I
finished second place
not bad I think there might have only
been one other person racing maybe
that's why this was actually really fun
I'm pretty impressed with the
performance let's just remember that
this entire game is being run off of
this tiny little handheld device and the
controller is actually really nice this
is giving you the functionality of the
elite controller by Xbox it doesn't have
as premium of a feel as the elite
controllers do but it's also much
lighter like the elite controller is
actually a very heavy device but this
has a nice very light feel the little
display is actually an OLED and you can
customize it I haven't customized mine
yet but to do that you just go into the
menu you can add different types of
wallpapers and things like that which is
pretty neat
foreign
I gotta have a feeling that this is
going to be like in the old days with
the Sega Game Gear if any of you guys
had one of those the way that you would
power through batteries on a family road
trip and then I would be making my
parents stop pull over at a gas station
not for snacks or to go to the bathroom
because I would want some freaking packs
of batteries to continue playing my game
until we finally got one of the
cigarette lighter power adapters so that
you could eat stay charged to the car
anyways if you know you know this is
available to pre-order right now for 700
with a less expensive 600 base Edition
that will be coming later this summer a
lot of people have been comparing this
to the steam deck which I personally
have not tried but both of these devices
are fairly new in this kind of genre of
PC handheld gaming market so from here
this is only going to get better this is
just the start let me know what you guys
think I would love to hear from you in
the comments Below have you played with
the steam deck is this something could
you be interested do you think you're
just gonna get the steam deck anyway
even though this is an option thank you
again for watching don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and hit the Bell
to be notified when I post new videos
I'll see you guys in the next one bye
[Music]